boris johnson is being accused of
undermining the fight against kovid 19
by launching a reorganization of the nhs
in england
in the middle of the pandemic the health
secretary matt hancock
is today announcing a shake-up that he
claims is based on lessons learned from
kovid
and will slash red tape but doctors say
now is not the time some of my
colleagues i think it thinks it sort of
beggars belief really that this is
happening
at this time when the nhs is is in
turmoil you know we don't need
reorganization we need a period of
stability and investment
the shake-up which rips up the nhs
reforms introduced by david cameron's
coalition government
in 2012 is said to have been triggered
by mr johnson's frustration
over the initial nhs response to
coronavirus
and his determination to take back
overall control
of health policy the government is
looking at restructuring the nhs do you
think
we do on sky's covid crisis learning the
lessons
there was backing for the reforms i
think we need to make this a really
big moment in the nhs history because
it's just been through the biggest
challenge
every single patient who's needed a
ventilator who's needed an intensive
care bed
has got one they'd like to know that
there was a proper plan in place
so that over time we can start to deal
with some of these gaps in the workforce
as well as nhs reorganization
the proposed legislation will also
include
measures to tackle obesity and the
advertising of junk
food before the 9pm watershed
labour is criticizing the lack of
proposals on social care in the white
paper
i'm disappointed there's almost nothing
on social care
in the proposals we'll look at the
details but to leave out social care i
think is
is to fail again to address what's been
a very very real problem in this
pandemic
but it's the timing of the shake-up and
accusations of a power grab
that are most contentious john craig sky
news